The Invention of Non-Alcoholic Grape Juice
You’ve probably heard about Jesus turning
water into wine, but Dr. Thomas Bramwell Welch
is a lesser-known drink magician who developed
a way to turn something that would have been
wine into a non-alcoholic version of the drink,
in an attempt to make an “unfermented sacramental
wine”.
Dr. Welch was a physician, a dentist and a
Methodist minister in Vineland, New Jersey.
At the time, Methodists were strongly opposed
to the consumption of alcohol.
This made serving wine for communion somewhat
hypocritical, a discrepancy that Welch was
quick to point out.
His stance on the matter was so strong that
he was even opposed to touching a container
holding wine—a problem, since he was the
communion steward.
The last straw was supposedly when a member
of the church turned up at the Welch home
one Sunday evening after partaking in a little
too much of the communion wine.
Welch was furious at the man’s raucous behaviour.
So, what to do about it?
Being something of a jack-of-all-trades, Welch
took on the endeavour himself.
He sought to come up with a way to bottle
grape juice so that it wouldn’t eventually
turn into wine.
In 1869, he pressed juice from Concord grapes,
filtered and bottled it in his own kitchen,
and then used Louis Pasteur’s innovative
new technique called “pasteurization.”
He boiled the bottles of grape juice, which
not only helped preserve the juice, but also
killed all of the yeast in the bottles.
This prevented fermentation, so the drinks
would not be alcoholic.
After successfully preparing the drink, Dr.
Welch delivered it to his church and even
advertised it to surrounding churches as well.
However, many clergymen were uninterested
in Dr. Welch’s Unfermented Wine; some even
called serving it “heresy.”
Needless to say, the unfermented sacramental
wine did not get off to a great start.
Welch was forced to set his product on the
back-burner, though he remained heavily involved
in the temperance movement.
That said, a small amount of his grape juice
continued to be produced for a few churches
in the area.
It wasn’t until Welch’s son, Charles,
who was also a dentist, started advertising
Welch’s in the 1890s that it became more
popular.
At the time, Thomas Welch’s advise to Charles
was the same as what so many parents tell
their children when the youngsters are pursuing
a new career path that the parent’s don’t
necessarily think has much of a future,
Now don’t think I’m trying to discourage
your pushing the grape juice.
It is right for you to do so, so far as you
can, without interfering with your profession
and your health.
Thanks to the rise of the Temperance Movement,
Charles’ profession was about to change.
The juice’s appearance at the World Fair
in Chicago didn’t hurt, either; thousands
of people were able to sample it there in
1893.
In 1896, Welch’s Fruit Juice Company became
too big for one family to handle.
To help meet the demand, Charles packed up
and moved the company to a factory in New
York, where he continued to grow the business.
(Thomas Welch died a few years later in 1903.)
Welch’s soon became the natural drink substitute
for wine; it was made from the same fruit
and suited the taste of the Temperance Society.
In 1913, Secretary of State William Jennings
Bryan hosted a dinner for the visiting British
ambassador; while it was traditional to serve
wine, Bryan decided to serve Welch’s instead,
making it more fashionable.
That same year, alcohol was banned on Navy
ships and Welch’s grape juice was served
instead.
Today, the company is a household name, featured
on juice, jellies, and jams.
They reportedly rake in nearly a half a billion
dollars every year and have since moved their
headquarters to Concord, Massachusetts, where
they grow cuttings from the original Concord
grape vine used.
Not bad for something that started out as
the result of a pet peeve of one man who simply
wanted to provide a way for people to take
communion without alcohol crossing their lips.
During the 1500-1800s Catholic, Protestant,
and even Puritans taught that alcohol was
a gift from God and was created by God to
be used in moderation for the pleasure of
man and to aid in health.
Drunkenness was viewed as a sin, as it often
is even today, but it’s only been relatively
recently in Christianity that drinking in
general has been considered sinful.
This change took place primarily due to the
increased concern over the negative effects
of drunkenness among the church, beginning
around the 18th century when mass-drunkenness
became a major problem largely thanks to the
Industrial Revolution, both because of the
concentration of the uneducated in urban slums
and technological advances in the mass production
of alcohol.
(Given the working conditions, hours and little
hope of escaping that life, it’s no wonder
so many chose to remain drunk as much as possible.)
During Prohibition, Grape growers of the day
began selling “bricks of wine”, which
were primarily blocks of “Rhine Wine”.
These often included the following instructions:
“After dissolving the brick in a gallon
of water, do not place the liquid in a jug
away in the cupboard for twenty days, because
then it would turn into wine.”
Thomas Welch was involved in the underground
railroad during the Civil War, successfully
smuggling several former slaves from the south
to freedom.
In the 1930s, Welch’s—then run by Thomas’
grandsons—distributed 10% of the company’s
shares to their 300 employees as a Christmas
present at the height of the Great Depression.
Welch’s initial foray into the world of
grape jam was in 1918 during World War I with
a product called “Grapelade.”
The entire first batch was snapped up by the
United States Army which doled it out to soldiers.
When the soldiers returned home, they demanded
the delicious Grapelade as part of their breakfast.
This went a long way in helping to popularize
the relatively newly invented peanut butter
and jelly sandwich.
Are you a fan of frozen juice concentrate?
You have Welch’s to thank for that!
In 1949, they introduced the first juice concentrate
you stored in the freezer to make juice later
with.
The Concord grape was developed from native
New England grapes by Ephraim Wales Bull in
Concord, Massachusetts.
Many varieties of grapes brought over from
Europe simply weren’t doing very well in
the Americas.
Bull planted around 22,000 seedlings before
he hit upon the perfect grape.
He presented his grapes to the public in 1853
and even won a prize for them at the Boston
Horticultural Society Exhibition.
The grapes brought him fame, but not fortune;
he earned $1000 for each cutting, but still
died a poor man.
His tombstone reads “He sowed—others reaped.”